today we are looking at centripetal
force this is one of the more unusual
forces that we see in physics and it's
almost always dealt with or comes up in
relation to circular motion so the first
thing we need to do is understand what
takes place during circular motion to
cause the actual motion to occur so the
first place we could consider this is in
relation to a satellite going around the
planet Earth so if we draw our planet
Earth there and we have our satellite
the satellite is moving at a velocity
which if we were drawing a force era
would take it in a straight direction
but then to stop it flying off into
space we have gravity that pulls it
straight towards the earth the resultant
force of these two takes the satellite
in a slightly less than straight off
direction it goes towards the earth if
we keep doing this and keep drawing our
satellite and each time we have this
arrow that's just going a little bit
off-center what we end up with is a
series of joined up arrows that if we
made them completely tiny would make up
the orbit that you see the satellite
going on so we have two components to
our circular motion we have gravity and
velocity as the forces involved now we
need to consider velocity and its parts
in its definition so velocity is a speed
in a direction and if we have a change
in velocity we have what we call
acceleration
now initially when we look at our
satellite we would say that it has the
same speed so how can it possibly have
an acceleration well we must remember
that velocity is made up of two key
parts it is speed in a direction and in
the case of our satellite the speed is
constant but the direction is changing
if we have a change in direction our
velocity is actually changing which
means we have acceleration that
acceleration can only be caused by a
force any change within our movement
must be caused by a force this force in
this case is causing our object to move
towards the center so we call it the
centripetal force and in the case of our
satellite that force is gravity so in
our current situation of a satellite
going around the planet we have a
centripetal force acting and the name of
that centripetal force in this case is
gravity now that is not the only force
that can act as a centripetal force we
have another two so in total we have
three common centripetal forces we have
gravity which is the most often quoted
in exams then we also have friction and
we have tension to give an example in
each case firstly gravity we've already
looked at that with satellites if we
want to look at friction we can consider
the bend on a road and a car going round
that bend as the car goes around the
bend its force and its direction of
movement wants it to go straight on
however the car because of its
grip on the road manages to turn around
that road that grip is a result of
friction so that friction is enabling
the car to turn the corner which means
that it is friction in this case which
is the centripetal force if we consider
tension we could consider a
merry-go-round with children playing on
it and when the children play on the
merry-go-round they may well decide to
hold on to the bar at the center as they
hold on to the bar at the center they
feel a force of tension as they move
around that tension in their arms is in
this case the centripetal force so we
have their three different examples of
centripetal force in action
so in summary centripetal force is a
force that acts towards the center
during circular motion it acts because
that although the velocity might be
constant there is within velocity a
change in direction which means a change
that leads to acceleration the
acceleration needs a force to act and
the three most common forces that we see
acting as a centripetal force are
gravity friction and tension